Hey guys,
You know, this there's a lot of craziness
that's going on in the world right now.
In Ephesians 5, it says do not take
any part in an unfruitful work of evil.
Of darkness.
But instead, expose them.
So I want to ask all of you who say that you
are reborn Christians ... what are you doing?
Should we not overcome evil with good?
Too many of you are doing nothing.
But the Bible says that we
should shine our lights.
But too many of you are
hiding and not doing anything.
So I want to encourage you not to just be
hearers of the word, but to be doers of the Word.
Obey God's Word.
Stand for the truth in love and in the Spirit.
That's my message to you today.